Netflix CEO Reed Hastings wants to take
over the world but global domination
won't be easy in January
Netflix opened for business in more than
130 countries at once look at the map of
where Netflix service is available
almost everywhere except China North
Korea and Syria Netflix is betting the
company on becoming the first global
television network yet selling Netflix
and new places gets harder from here and
the expansion is masking the company's
problems at home in the u.s. Netflix is
finding it tough to sign up customers
the number of new streaming subscribers
fell 18% in the last quarter of 2015
meanwhile the number of international
subscribers is growing fast that global
growth is a big reason stock investors
fell in love with Netflix now the bad
news the company's international
business is losing money hand over fist
and Netflix faces many obstacles in new
markets like India there's competition
from Amazon local web video companies
and not everyone has access to the
Internet it has been a bad idea to
underestimate Netflix the company's
market value is 14 times what it was
three and a half years ago but the
combination of tough sledding abroad and
slowing growth domestically is a
worrying trend